hey welcome everybody to the CBS this
morning Facebook live I am joined today
by dr. Mark Hyman he is the author of
food what the heck should I eat which is
something I asked myself on a daily
basis usually with the refrigerator open
what the heck should I eat walk into the
grocery store yeah yeah and well I think
if you're asking yourself that question
that's when you're heading towards
frozen pizza if you're in the grocery
store at that time so this is a really
interesting book it really sort of
breaks down a lot of the myths that
we've been hearing about food and tells
you what this lot how accurate the
science is and how it is and tells you
what to eat yes but I thought to myself
when I got this I've read so many books
on food did you know it all I know it
all already yeah and I'm sure a lot of
other people are gonna think that when
they see this on the bookshelf why did
you write this book well I've been
practicing nutritional medicine for 30
years and treating people with food and
I've been studying nutrition for 40
years and I'm that old and I realize
that people are totally confused that
people here competing things eggs or bad
eggs are good mean it's bad meats good
coconut oils bad coconuts good it's bad
again it's like so confusing all right
and so how do you make sense of it how
do you know how to interpret the science
what do we know in 2018 about what's
true about what we should be eating and
it's actually not that complicated and
you've got so many competing the Paleo
vegan keto low-fat high fat low carb
high car it's like enough to give
everybody a headache and give up I feel
like you've been reading my food diary
everything that I've probably tried over
the last 10 15 years or so in the
beginning of this book you talked about
the fact that we've forgotten that food
is medicine yeah tell me more about that
well we we actually had this thousands
of years ago with Epocrates who said let
food be thy medicine and medicine be thy
food but now we think of food mostly as
Energy's calories right calorie
restriction is the way to lose weight
you want to eat less exercise more
except there's really no evidence that
that works because we've been getting
fatter and fatter and we're getting that
advice from our doctors and
nutritionists from the government from
food industry which should make you
suspicious and the truth is that food is
actually far more than calories it's
information it's like instructions that
talks to your body with every single
bite so what changes
your gene expression and regulates your
hormones it changes your immune system
can create inflammation and reduce
inflammation affects your microbiome
affects your brain chemistry literally
with every single bite so it's like code
that programs your biology and if you're
putting junk in your gonna get junk out
and so why disease happens so food it
turns out is probably one of the most
powerful drugs on the planet we can
reverse type 2 diabetes in a few weeks
changing people's diet but there's no
medication that can do that right you
know we're living at a time where we
have access to so much information
almost too much information and when I
saw that thing about medicine food being
a medicine in your book I thought it
made me think about what medical
students are learning about food nothing
I mean 25 percent of schools have the
required amount of nutrition education
in medical school and of that it's
usually about like nutritional
deficiency diseases like scurvy or
malnutrition like kwashiorkor marasmus
which is stuff we don't see we see over
nutrition all over we're overfed and
undernourished so we basically have too
many calories not enough nutrients and
you see people who are obese even people
have a gastric bypass little kids
they're massively nutritionally
deficient so was that part of the
problem our doctors aren't being trained
the way they should and what else
because we're we're sort of battling
systemic right there's a number of
reasons we're so confused first yeah
doctors don't learn anything about
nutrition to the food industry funds a
lot of research so if the food industry
funds a study it's 8 to 50 times more
likely to show a benefit for that
product the Dairy Council funds a study
I milk guess what it's a health if the
soda industry funds a study on soda and
obesity guess what there's no link right
then of course we have science itself
which is confusing cuz a lot of
nutritional studies are done on
populations over a long period of time
but they're not cause and effect studies
they just so correlation so every day I
wake up the Sun comes up they're not
related but it's 100% correlation so we
can see oh eating meat seems to cause
heart disease well why because when you
look at the population who was studied
at the time they actually thought meat
was bad so people who ate me didn't care
about their health right so they weighed
more they ate 800 calories more day they
didn't exercise they didn't eat fruits
and vegetables
take their vitamins they drank more they
smoke more of course they had more heart
disease it wasn't the meat and when you
look at studies for example where meat
eaters and vegetarians both are shopping
at health food stores they both have
their risk of death reduced in half so
this is an example of confusing science
and then of course you get the
government which is heavily influenced
by lobbyists like I said before there's
half a billion dollars spent by 600
lobbyists for the farm bill which should
be called a food pill which governs our
food stamps and many other things and
and that's what's influencing policy our
guy dietary guidelines are influenced by
industry who has on you know
illegitimate relations with the right
people their own agenda
their own agenda yes it's not about food
as medicine it I mean we spend 7 billion
dollars on food stamps a year if you
look at junk food for the food stamps 46
million people had food stamps it's
probably by a factor of 10 more than any
other category of food the junk food as
a whole and so does the number one line
item at 7 billion a year which is 20
billion servings a year the government
pays for the poor sure which is yeah I
mean they pay for it on the back end
with Medicare Medicare bankrupting our
country so it's it's sadly very industry
influence in terms of why we have our
dietary policy so all those reasons lead
to this confusion right so the book
breaks down the foods and the science
related to it you got it in categories
it's really clear yeah here's the food
here are some of the myths yeah test
yourself to see if you know and then
here's the science here's where they got
it right here's when they got it wrong
and here's where they book because it's
so easy to read um you talked about and
we talked about this earlier but just
flipping through the book we talked
about milk yeah and one of the questions
that I got wrong was about the number of
adults being lactose intolerant I
thought lactose intolerance this is a
handful of people it's not true no
globally seventy five percent of the
world's population is lactose intolerant
so the anomaly is being lactose tolerant
that's usually northern European people
who can tolerate more dairy but the
dairy we're eating isn't the dairy we
ate right we first of all until we're
agriculturalists about 12,000 years ago
nobody dairy you wouldn't be milking a
saber-toothed tiger right but we ate
heirloom cows they had less inflammatory
forms of protein in them called casein
and now we have these feedlot cows that
are all hybridized they're all the same
kind of cow and there's 70
one bull practically the whole country
and you've got high levels inflammation
and milk has been linked to cancer like
prostate cancer autoimmune diseases like
type 1 diabetes digestive issues as well
as inflammation acne eczema allergies
all sorts of issues not even helping
bones we think it's great for strong
bones but actually that's not true so we
had all these got milk ads well guess
what the government funded part of those
the national health promotion dairy
boards actually funded a lot of those
ads with the dairy industry and then the
FTC said no no you can't say that
because there's no evidence that milk
protects against fractures and skim milk
which we make all our kids drink low-fat
milk that actually leads to more obesity
in kids because well that yeah the
chocolate in strawberry milk but the
actual dairy has no fat if you have skim
milk and that makes you hungry you eat
more yeah so let's break down some of
these popular diets let's look at sort
of the high protein diet that's the
Atkins or you know what I'm talking
about it's very very popular now so you
eat meat vegetables what are the pros
what are the cons well I think the
highest training diet is the ketogenic
diet right people think of as Atkins but
I think you can do a plant rich
ketogenic diet and not be heavy on the
protein in fact heavy on the protein is
probably not a great idea because that
actually turns into sugar for you too
much protein in your blood so it turns
out that the fat is actually what our
bodies need to thrive so we probably
need about 50% of our calories as fat
which makes people sort of hair stand on
in but the truth is we need no buy
calories and by volume we need to mostly
plants so 70% of your plate should be
vegetables and and that doesn't have
very many calories right
it's a 21 cups of broccoli has 750
calories the broccoli but red meats okay
so meat let's talk about me so there's
really three issues moral if you're a
Buddhist monk okay that's fine
environmental and yes our way of factory
farming animals is biggest contributor
to climate change so we should really
not be doing that and third is the
health effects what about grass-finished
me what about sustainably wild meat we
know about the data on meat that doesn't
show us that it's harmful for example
like I said you have these studies that
were done over many years that showed a
link between disease and heart and meat
but the truth is that the meat studies
were done on populations who who didn't
think meat was how
Phee and they would be avoiding it so
the reason they didn't get disease when
they avoided meat was not because they
weren't eating meat it's because they
were doing other health field things
like the healthy user have you're
exercising eating fruits and vegetables
and so forth and so we really have to
look at the science carefully and
there's really not a lot of evidence
that meat is harmful it's great source
of protein antioxidants and what about
yes what about cholesterol so saturated
fat is the boogeyman okay so that's like
a huge issue in our society because
we're supposed to eat low saturated fat
to reduce cholesterol but did you know
that breast milk is 25 percent saturated
fat that that that actually the
government's and and the American Heart
Association's that we have 10 percent or
5 percent saturated fat so maybe we
should ban breast milk I don't know many
babies are crying out now just about
that know and the dietary guidelines are
based on sort of ignoring huge amounts
of data that the National Academy of
Sciences recently sort of showed and and
now we know that actually saturated fat
doesn't cause heart disease that in you
look at 17 large reviews of all the
science showing there's no link between
dietary saturated fat cholesterol and
and I'm sorry dietary and saturated fat
and heart disease it does raise your LDL
cholesterol but it also raises the good
one and it lowers triglycerides so we
have to rethink our whole approach to
this ok another trending diet vegan diet
yes um you know increasingly I keep it's
reading about how it's sort of the
fastest-growing
yes or twice or flexy die or whatever
but people are leaning towards vegan
right in your book you need animal
protein yeah a lot of vegans your hair's
on fire when they hear that because they
insist that you can get it all the
protein you need from a plant is that
true to get what you need in a six ounce
piece of fish or chicken yeah you need
three cups of beans and that's a lot of
beans and it comes with 100 grams of
carbs now beans aren't terrible but
they're they're also low in an amino
acid called leucine which is critical
for making muscle and if you don't have
enough of that you can't make enough
muscles so as you age you need more
protein there's good evidence about that
and so what's the best quality protein
it's animal protein but it should be
organic sustainably raised grass finish
and it's more expensive for sure but as
more of us do that we're gonna actually
end up causing an increase in the
availability and a decrease in the price
local or organic I mean or both
I mean ideally both but you know those
are hierarchies of choices right first
get people off process food they need
real food and then you can kind of go up
the hierarchy of the quality of the real
food right there's a quality of a
feedlot cow and a quality of a
grass-finished cow is very different a
mega three fats the nutrients lack of
hormones antibiotics like pesticides so
it's worth reading those labels if
you're buying chicken it's worth it
we're it's worth finding out if they're
grass-fed or whatever well chickens
don't eat grass but yeah yeah cows eat
grass I think you know I think most of
our diet should be plants I agree we
should have a plant rich diet with small
amounts of sustainably raised or
harvested animal foods whether it's
chicken fish or meat and we should be
eating a lot of good fats and that's
pretty much the diet it's low starch and
sugar and you can have a very high
starch and sugar vegan diet right chips
and soda Oh totally and I know someone
who went vegan ate nothing but french
fries for like three years and it
depends on your metabolism some people
do better some people don't we're all
good print right so some people do fine
but others you know gain weight and you
know have issues because they're eating
a lot of starch grains and beans have a
lot of storage so you actually answer
the question what the heck should I eat
with a diet I thought it was called the
pagan diet but it's not no I can diet
pigan vegan diet it's it's actually not
even it died it's just a set of
principles of what we should be doing
right and I was on a panel once with a
couple of friends of mine one was a
paleo doc one was a vegan cardiologist
and they were fighting I'm like listen
guys if you're pale you're vegan I must
be a pig in there was a joke and then I
and then I realized wait a minute
there's some common things that they
share in terms of their perspective on
food and there's like nuances that we
can come through so I basically it's
it's mostly plant rich diet lots of fats
good fats it's if you're gonna eat
animal foods have the the ones that are
sustainably raised or harvested or
grass-finished lots of nuts and seeds
small amounts of grains and beans mostly
like low gluten grains or if you're
eating gluten grains don't eat wheat
have rye or barley because they're less
change in terms of some of the taxes per
week and don't eat junk well I mean like
I always joked like if you wouldn't have
it in your cupboard you shouldn't have
it in your food right people don't have
red dye in there
covered or you know maltodextrin bottle
that they pour on their food I mean
these are all things that are added by
the food industry to enhance flavor
taste consistency and they're not things
we should be eating their food like
substances they're not real food how
should you know people get really
emotional about food they do religion
politics and nutrition are basically the
most inflammatory topic seriously you
know what do you want people to know if
they're just having a hard time making
those good food choices I think what if
people are really stuck people
understand there's certain foods in the
food supply are addictive so sugar
mainly and processed foods are designed
to be addictive you know I've met with
top leaders in the food industry and
they explain to me how they have taste
Institute's where they hire craving
experts to create the Bliss point of
food and heavy users I mean these are
their internal terminology about
creating addictive foods and they
harvest taste buds and put them in the
lab and then they test it and things
against them to create the most
pleasurable experience and we know
biologically that it affects your brain
like cocaine or heroin or alcohol and
that we can map that out so if you are
really stuck and addicted you need to
sort of do a detox and I have a 10 day
program in the book which is essentially
getting you off of all the junk
resetting things so you can start again
and then you don't want it like I walked
by a bakery with all these croissants
and muffins and it doesn't even look
like food like why would I eat that oh
that cuz it's a rock like why would I
eat that it doesn't call my name anymore
I used to very good well the book is
food what the heck should I eat dr. Mark
Hyman thank you so much it dispels the
myths it gives you the science and gives
you a little bit of a roadmap so you can
pick the right foods